everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm today I'm gonna be going
over match from round 5 2014 candidates
tournament today's feature match is
gonna be between Peters fiddler playing
the white pieces we just saw him in last
round actually losing so definitely
wants to get back on track here in round
5 his opponent is toe plov previous
world champion so definitely one of the
top players in the world he's gonna be
playing as black we're going to get into
it starts with pani for pani 5 9 f3
knight c6 Bishop here to b5 this is the
right Lopez very very common opening a
lot of players start out with learning
in chess we have pawn here to a6 brings
the bishop back Knight to f6 and then
castle very interesting move from
Topalov with his next move something we
don't see very often and that is the
molar defense and that's Bishop here to
c5 pretty intrigued by this defense
probably gonna make a follow-up video to
this opening to go a little bit more in
depth about some different ideas that
Black has and how white can really
counter-attack this well right really
needs to do is control this square right
here on the 4 it's putting a lot of
pressure his opponent with his Bishop
here on c5 it's pawn here on e5 and his
night here on c6 so first what's gonna
play pawn here to c3 getting ready to
push forward with his pawn here on d4 he
does have his pawn here on c3 it's Queen
here on d1 and his a night here on f3
all defending that square now the pawns
gonna push forward to b5 attacking this
Bishop pretty calm and the bishop can
come back here to b3 or C to Swit lured
decides to go ahead and bring this
Bishop back here to a c2 and then we see
pawn to d5 again pushing in the center
of the board really putting his opponent
to the test Peter Svidler plays this
pawn here today for getting counter
attacking the sin of the board doesn't
want to give up the center too early on
in this game especially in the right
Lopez things can get pretty out of hand
if you don't control the center of the
board decides to go ahead and take here
on e4 this again is the molar defense
pretty common from both sides and then
we see the the queen take on
the one after the root comes over then
the ponds gonna take here on f3 then
this particular case the most common
move is actually for the bishop to take
here on f2 but tow club afterwards said
he really just didn't like this
variation he thinks he found a small
improvement and I would agree with him
that the common line after Bishop takes
on f2 is King to f1 the knight now comes
down here to a g4 to protect this Bishop
but then the bishop takes the material
here on e4 it's very centralized there's
real no clear path for black to continue
again how is he really going to attack
and so from here White's somewhat has
the advantage and black is just trying
to figure out how to continue his attack
so tupelov said that he thinks he found
a much better variation and that's what
he played in this particular game he
played pawn takes here on f3 and I think
this was a much better play much better
preparation and something that Peters
fiddler was definitely not looking for
Peters fiddling now played upon takes
here on f6 again you definitely want to
make sure you get that material then
after the pawn takes back on f6 there's
a nice little in-between move a lot of
players would be rushed to play pawn
takes here on g3 and that would actually
be a mistake the opponent can now come
bring his bishop to h3 rook over here to
g8 a lot of problems for his opponent
instead there's kind of a waiting move
and that's Bishop here to e4 putting a
lot of pressure pinning down this Knight
to this rook here on a8 also attacking
the pawn if the pawn can't really take
here on to you too because again it
would just take this Knight right here
so it definitely has to somewhat
defender that so the bishop is gonna
come here to d7 and then white says okay
I still know that I have this material
right here but instead I'm gonna play
pawn here to a4 because again the pond
can no longer come here to g2 even
though the bishop is protecting the
knight the pawn on b5 this is pretty
much lethal it spinning down this night
at the knight moves then the roofs gonna
fall here on a8 the pawn can't take
because again this
rooks gonna swing up here to a this is
gonna be all sorts of problem that's
exactly what white wants to do and so
black decides that he can't take this
material back so all these in-between
moves from Peters fiddler even though he
said he wasn't very familiar with the
molar defense this variation that took
life played here with taking on f3 he
definitely played exceptionally well and
actually has a nice little
counter-attack going now black decides
to go ahead and castle on the Queen side
somewhat okay it's not quite as safe but
you know the King sides kind of
blistered here with the Jeep on moving
and he definitely needs to make sure
that his rook is no longer under attack
or being pinned down by another piece so
this is definitely gonna be a very good
for black here Peter Svidler decides to
go ahead and take here on it b5 trying
to just break this up he would really
like his opponent to play pawn to b5 he
can really get his rook involvement of
the game this could be a lot of trouble
black decides to go ahead and instead
play Knight here to e5 protecting this
pawn another move that white has is just
to take this pawn not even have the
doubled pawns over here still have a lot
of protection in front of his King and
still controlling this long diagonal
this would be very very bad for blacks
who decides to go ahead and play Knight
here to e5 has a nice little outpost
because this pawn here on f6 and it
protects this pawn here on f3 we now see
the bishop comes here to f4 attacking
this Knight and then the bishops gonna
take that material here on b5 so tupolev
actually took what looked like somewhat
of a negative and now has a nice little
outpost here it's gonna be very
difficult again if your pun doesn't have
the Queen on board it can be very
difficult for them to attack your King
so the King is somewhat safe and Black
has you know fairly decent amount of
sinner control he does have protection
here on the pawn on a6 so this rook is
not going to be swinging into action
anytime soon so to Bob's got a pretty
good setup especially fit playing as
black in the Moller defense this is
exactly kind of what you want coming
into this tournament all your
preparation if you can give a slight
little edge when you're playing second
is black this is definitely going to be
very good now we see Knight here to a3
attacking this Bishop and then we see
the exchange off of rooks both sides
just want to control this long D file
right here now the bishop is gonna come
down here to e - it's an outpost that
that's true it's kind of an interesting
outpost you have the knight defending
the pawn that's defending the bishop but
the outpost on the second rank is not
nearly as strong as if it's in the
center of the board of controls a lot
this rook can immediately just move and
all of a sudden this bishop outpost
isn't doing too much now all of a sudden
White has somewhat of a counter-attack
in the center of the board the key again
controls this long file right here where
before there's kind of a duel off so
nice little series of moves for Peters
fidlow definitely getting himself back
in the game now the Rick's gonna swing
over here to g8 attacking the pawn I
don't really know that this is
necessarily the best move I think Bishop
here to d6 kind of blocking off any
mobility that this rook has is fine the
rook swinging over here to g8 attacking
this would be fine and dandy
except that white just has pawn here to
g3 solidifying a nice little apples for
this Bishop here on f4 and pretty much
stops any attack that black has again
just kind of a wasted move for black
then the bishop decides to go ahead and
take in in exchange pieces here on a3 so
the knight is off the board and now we
have the pawn take again another
interesting move I think from topal off
if we look at this position right here
we see that White has five pawns Black
has six pawns but what what do both
sides really have on the board so White
has both of his bishops which can be
very very powerful if it's an open game
which it is and if there's pawns on both
sides of the board which there are
that's a double thumbs up for white also
Black has triple pawns on the F file so
although he is up a pawn and material
he's probably down in board state just
because these three pawns maybe count as
one and a half because they're just very
difficult to really do too much and
again white right now has the center
control to board and he has the double
Bishop pair
the night's gonna come back here to g6
attacking this bishop here on f4
definitely don't want to keep up that
bishop pair Peters fella worked too hard
to get that so he's gonna bring his
bishop back here to e3 do a little
retreating rook over here to EA trying
to control this long file Bishop here to
f5 check this is also a pretty menacing
square that black has to deal with
although it's not an outpost yet it's
gonna be very difficult for black to
move this King goes to b7 rook back here
to a d4 nice little outpost and then the
rook here to e5 attacking the bishop and
now we see pawn here to g5 protecting
the bishop here and then the pawn
pushing forward to a5 trying to get some
a counter play on the board
we then see palm pushing forward to h3
protecting this pawn as well now if we
look at the board we'd really like to
see from black we have a knight here to
h4 but unfortunately for black white
could just now play Bishop takes on 87
this is gonna be bad so before he does
that he decides to go ahead and play
pawn to h5 trying to break this up so
that if later he wants to play Knight
here to h4 and attack it or anything he
can do that without having to worry
about this pawn he can also move his
knight anywhere else he wants to the
bishops now I'm gonna come back here
attacking the King attacking this pawn
right here the King comes to a6
somewhat of an aggressive move not
really sure that he has to be this
aggressive I think it's probably a
little safer to come back here to see a
2 even if the bishop comes to f5 it can
kind of have a few different options
dance around the board since white has
more of a presence he can kind of just
dance back and forth and have a drawn
game if he wants to have a threefold
repetition but in the game he does
decide to play King to a6 a little bit
more exposed than I would like we now
see the pawn take here on h5 attacking
this night the night is forced to move
or capture the rook decides to capture
it on h5 and then we see the rook
swinging up here to be a very
interesting move from White's because he
somewhat leaves this pawn hanging on a
three but it's actually not hanging the
root can't take here on H three because
then the root can swing over here to b8
threatening so many different things
with all the bishops just controlling
all these squares over here it's gonna
be very very difficult for block to
continue he could bring his rook up here
attacking the bishop but again bishop
here to b7 it's gonna just be very very
bad we have any discovered attack with
the rook now after the bishop moves back
here to f3 nice little windmill move
it's going to win this material here on
e 2 so again all sorts of trouble black
can't really take it right away and said
decides to go ahead and play his knight
here to e5 getting ready to come over
here to kind of block off any attack and
now we see pawn here to a4 now would
even be worse for the rook to take care
on h3 because now it's just checkmate
that's just gg pack it up you lose kind
of thing so again haul this pawn is over
here it's a passed pawn
it's unprotected it's still kind of
protected by all the attacks that white
has on the board we now see pawn here to
c6 again giving it out for the King to
now come here to b7 if the record is
swinging over so definitely just playing
a defensive game from black right here
trying to hold on to potentially a draw
we now see the rook over here to b8
putting a lot of pressure again he has
so many different attacks the Knights
gonna swing over here to c4 it would
have been another bad move if the rook
took here on h3 we now see the bishop
centralized with D for protecting on
here controlling a lot more squares now
also attacking a pawn here on f6 again
if we look at it black is still actually
up in material but as far as game state
his pieces really aren't doing too much
he's kind of on the defensive his Kings
being just chased around the board and
he just can't do a whole heck of a lot
now the pawns gonna push forward here to
c5 it is being protected by this rook
over here on h5 then the bishops going
to take some of that material is going
to be gone
now the Knights gonna come up here to b6
trying to block stuff up we have the
Bishop to d8 the knight moves now the
rooks gonna swing over
year to a 8 attacking and then gonna
start gobbling up some material right
here we see an exchange of pieces and
whites now okay giving up the double
bishop pair the double bishop pair did
what it needed to do it allowed him to
force a lot of the action now in this
particular case if we look at it both
sides both have a rope they both have a
bishop white has three passed pawns his
opponent has two pawns but their double
pawns it's gonna be very very difficult
for black to do anything except draw or
lose this game so we're going to
continue black decides to go ahead and
take material now we see the rook over
here to f5 attacking the bishop is
forced to move so it comes back here to
d5 now the rooks attacking the pawn here
on c3 Bishop comes back protecting that
now the Brooks wings up here protecting
his pawn here on f7 if both of his pawns
fall it's gonna be bad news as well palm
pushes forward to f4 h4 excuse me this
is going to be the key factor right here
these past pawns
you always want to push past pawns and
sometimes there's just too much pressure
for your opponent to deal with the
King's gonna swing over here to the a
trying to rush over to the side to
protect this square the bishop now here
to a g5 nice little outpost attacking
the King's gonna continue to move up the
board rook here to d5 palm pushing
forward opening up the door for the rook
to kind of control the square here on h7
pushing forward with h5
now we see c4 nice little square here d4
with the rook and then kind of the the
last straw that the total of just made a
mistake and it's rook takes here on c3
does gain material but unfortunately the
pawn can now push forward and there's no
way for topal off to stop it now there's
probably still going to lose the game
even if he doesn't take with his rook
here on c3 this just kind of made sure
that he loses the work now comes back
here to c8 pawn continues to push
forward we see King here to f7 allowing
this rook to kind of control it and then
again kind of the
from Peter Svidler to make sure that
black can't do anything
it's Bishop here to d7 and this puts
your case toe blob was forced to resign
there's no way to really stop it you
can't really get his king over to stop
it if he tries King here to do seven
protecting it again there's just no
great squares for him we can now see the
rook come up here to d7 check it can't
come if it comes here to h8 that's gonna
be bad news because that's checkmate
so definitely don't want that to happen
can't come here to g8 because it can't
if it goes anywhere else
pawn just gonna push forward and check
get a queen potentially check depending
on where the king is but black would
just be down way too much material so
again this position black was forced to
resign great game from Peters Villa
again coming off as lost yesterday to go
ahead and beat one of the top players
today gets himself back in the running
an on tide today he's still leading the
pack but all in all we've had some
exciting exciting chests hope you guys
are enjoying the commentary if you
haven't already check out the new
Facebook page the link in the
description and I'll see you on the next
video thanks for watching